far out in the Indian Ocean two men
search for sharks
QV tree is a dive guide and naturalist
Rian Johnson is a shark scientist their
dive site is a labyrinth of reefs
caverns and caves and it holds a special
secret unusual sunken pits that look
like they've been carved by giant
whirlpools these places are special they
hold a magnetic attraction to sharks
huge numbers of sharks the very shape of
these pits channel's the water into
violent vortices bad for divers but good
for sharks but what exactly attracts the
Sharks remains a mystery at the base of
the pit lies an entrance tunnel like a
secret passage at the end of the town a
chamber of light
Hugh calls this the cathedral bid it is
like God talking to you and then a pair
appears right in the cathedrals
floodlights
soon followed by another one and then a
large and very pregnant female shark
arrives on the scene to see a breeding
pair and a pregnant female is an
excellent sign it's much harder tagging
sharks like these I'm used to big great
white sharks who aren't afraid of coming
close one shark is bolder than the rest
and comes close success
and then another the tag doesn't harm
the shark and the animal gets used to it
quickly the tag will allow me to follow
the shocks when they leave the pit each
tag gives off a radio signal that he can
pick up on his topside receiver
they'll follow the shark all day if
necessary she completes her journey
three miles away and rests and then
sharks swimming down the channel - they
must swim fast to keep up the Sharks
lead them over a wall and into another
shark pit
everywhere they look sharks 50 60 70
sharks looks like it is a nursery
because it is only young sharks here
that's incredible I can see the shot
that you tagged over there it's the
shark from the cathedral and another
arrival from Cathedral it's clear the
Sharks are moving between the pits up
above the surface of the basin pit is
churning the foaming water attracts the
Sharks something Hugh has noticed in all
the shark pits few suspects there's a
good reason why the Sharks like this
foaming water I think that all those
bubbles in the water bring extra oxygen
into the bit could this explain why the
Sharks like these pits a lot of sharks
including the black tails have to
continuously swim to breathe
so if it is a situation that within the
pit there are high levels of dissolved
oxygen it might give them a greater
chance to rest they don't have to swim
quite so much to get the same amount of
oxygen Ryan needs to sample water from
all the shark pits
what's going on is that these waves are
crashing up against the island and it
hits the rocks and all this oxygen-rich
water gets shot down right into the pit
that's what the Sharks love that's what
they seem to be looking for back at the
dive headquarters
Ryan checks to see if his results
confirm his theory when I first hopped
into the water outside of the pits while
swimming through these normal levels of
dissolved oxygen but as I swam into the
pits the levels of oxygen increased
around four to five percent so it seems
that this almost Jacuzzi of super
oxygenated water is what's drawing all
these sharks into the pits so Hugh was
right after all
Hugh and Ryan's expedition has unlocked
some of the mysteries surrounding this
very special hidden world there is no
doubt that these pits are critical
habitat for the local survival the shark
species I want to keep those places
where we have seen the shops I want to
keep them secret because I want this
shop to be at peace
for now the location of the shark pits
will be Hugh's secret